The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah.
It's weird.
How would you feel bad for killing an elephant but other animals is like a rat.
You kind of deserve it.
Yeah.
Rack gets hit by a car,
you cheer,
you like,
Oh yeah,
you're fucking loser.
I hit it myself.
Right.
Yeah.
It's,
we're,
we're totally w you know,
bias towards certain types of animals and for sure it's like why we uh,
how do they say it while we feed pigeons,
but we'll be like,
we shoot bald eagles.
Just majestic.
Yeah,
no,
you want it.
Do you see that Beluga whale that they caught that had a,
a net?
It had a harness on it and they think that the Russians were writers and you
know,
they think it was,
they were using it as a bio weapon.
Like they would strap a missile to this thing.
Oh.
And then tell the whale to go to boats.
How do you,
tell me a little about this way.
I was trained to go towards boats hold and it had this harness on it and they,
they think that what they did was they trained this thing to go towards boat,
the choking the shit out of that thing.
Well it,
you could use something like that to hold a bomb.
So you train it to go towards the boat and then when it would hit the boat it
would detonate the bomb and explode.
So they must have given this way or some sort of food reward for banging into
the boat.
Cause it,
yeah.
So they,
they cut it free of this uh,
this harness,
I mean this is total speculation.
They don't know where the harness came from,
but I'm hoping someone was trying to ride it and they weren't as probably a bomb
though.
I'm pretty sure.
Pretty sure it's a bomb.
I'm pretty sure look at this whale found off Norway coast believed to be spine
[inaudible] bunch of cameras and stuff too.
I might just be click baity bullshit too.
Right.
Who wrote this article?
Are they an expert?
Are they a security expert?
Do they just have a whale with a harness?
We don't really know what the,
how often do whales and harnesses show up?
The fact that you're an expert can speak intelligently about it.
I think that the US government owed it's red equipment of Saint Petersburg on
the strap.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
But if I wanted to trick people into thinking that the Russians were involved,
I would make it super obvious.
Right.
That too.
Yeah.
Why would they write that?
We've got a fake train.
I'll whale and incentive Zach liquids.
You got to look into.
Exactly.
Made in Russia by Russia.
Um,
I would write maiden rush on it is all in English to Chinese Russian letters to
property of mother Russia.
I love Russia.
I think the government did that with dolphins sea.
See if that's true that the government trained dolphins for weapons,
20 of them,
something like that.
Yeah.
I think US government did that.
Find out what they trained dolphins to blow up boats.
Damn Dude.
What a,
what a place.
What a place we live in now basically trained dolphins to BG hottest.
But they didn't know it.
They didn't know they were g.
At least the jihad,
his nose mean you tricked him into going 72 virgins and blowing up.
You trick them,
God,
but the Dolphin doesn't even know is going to die.
Yeah,
probably would be like,
what?
Wait a minute while I get fish.
I love fish.
He just thinks he's going to get fish.
If he bumps into the boat.
What's this thing on my back?
Oh,
whatever.
I'll do.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
that's it.
Four things now coming.
Yeah.
This says it's a myth.
Oh,
it's a math.
What's a myth that wouldn't be high spread dealt this information.
Yeah.
Well who says that?
The navy.
It's a place.
Stories are coming up with Joe's second guesses.
Everything.
That's true.
Is that true?
Who wrote them?
But then in 2015 it says that the US Navy's combat dolphin is our serious
military assets.
So yeah,
started,
stopped and started back up.
Did it go?
So why don't they,
why are they sending dog one of these build robots to do it?
Because the robots aren't as advanced as her wild dolphin.
They can't go through the water the way a dolphin can and it would look like a
robot.
Oh,
Dolphin.
The Dunkin to do shit.
They're always in the water.
Oh right.
And get something that's an organic part of the environment.
They're not going to kill every dolphin that comes near the boat,
you know?
So they see a dolphin.
The thing it's just a dolphin,
right?
Bunk.
Why don't they,
why don't they have a missile painted like a dolphin?
And by the time they get it,
it's like,
oh shit.
Going too fast and creating killer dolphins escape naval training base in search
of love.
Yeah,
it's accurate.
For some reason.
I don't know why I escaped during Hurricane Katrina.
They've escaped multiple times.
It's like an arm,
a Howard for just training more.
These dolphins keep escaping everything out.
We are tailored off,
off.
It's smarter than us.
They keep escaping.
How do we,
not super smart.
How do we not keep a hold of these dolphins?
Not on the loose.
I don't know.
It's very confusing when you look it up.
So Ukrainian military dolphins,
not actually on the loose.
Who says that?
That's the G.
Dot Gov
hey,
you know what?
You're going to dolphins.
My Fun Dolphin fact that dolphins are one of the few animals that have sex for
pleasure.
Yeah.
One of the few chimps.
Dolphins,
people.
Yep.
And uh,
dogs.
Wild dogs are tracks for fun.
No,
I guess I want to fuck your leg.
What are they trying to do?
Are you sure?
Right.
That's all
we trying to get to the point.
It's a good point.
What are they trying to prove?
Yeah.